david je vais te tutoyer l'air ça ne
dérange pas les plaisirs à ce petit jeu
connaît on est tombé dans le banditisme
à 14 ans ouais qu'est ce tu as fait ben
c'est l'escaladé
voilà de moi j'habitais une tour à
l'époque il y avait la cour des miracles
il ya longtemps nous c'était la tour des
miracles il y avait les vols et
cambriolages l'alcool la drogue la
touques on a baigné là dedans pour nous
c'était on pensait donc à ça donc c'est
l escalade les vols à l'étalagé
dévoilant filouterie voit la filouterie
ses entrées dans les moyennes surfaces
sans âme sans violence on allait dans
les bureaux on chercher la clé du coffre
donc les gens faisaient leurs courses
non utilisés puis lille à 14 ans on
était bons élèves on se débrouille et
bien et moi j'ai décidé de me
débrouiller
bah ouais il nous parlait de notre
avenir mais nous l'avenir c'était
aujourd'hui demain c'est savoir comment
manger comment s'habiller c'était ça
donc nous nous parlait de plus tard de
travailler quand on aura 18 enfin nous
c'était là il fallait faire voilà
c'était alors vous avez fait quel type
de délit au début mais comme j'ai dit
vol à l'étalagé
on commence par le vol à l'étalagé un
classique pour manger pour s'habiller et
tous ensuite bas nous on était consul a
fait tout à fait la tentative de
braquage à la société générale
il ya une étape quand même pas quand
même on passe pas du fait que certaines
pistes au noir on exactement exactement
donc voilà donc les volants filouterie
c'est à dire la journée on rentrait dans
les magasins partout on vous aider en
chercher la clé du coffre dans les
bureaux en bureaux et on prenait ce
qu'est le contenu du coffre sans arme et
sans violence
ensuite on les enfants n'écoutent et
surtout par ces temps mais attention
parce qu'on va pas faire l'apologie du
bol ou new delhi ces lois parce que vous
allez voir ce qu'a fait david après et
justement c'est justement pour ça qu'on
l'a invité ce soir parce que c'est voilà
c'est pas parce qu'ils racontent qu on
dit que c'est bien on y raconte
exactement oui il faut sur un compte qui
l'a fait au début pour faire exactement
donc voilà l'escaladent ensuite on je me
suis très vite nous spécialiser dans la
neutralisation des systèmes d'armes avec
mes amis ont cambriolé les banques la
nuit sans armes sans violence on
rentrait ont découpé les coffres forts
au chalumeau des coupeurs et ou à
l'ancienne et puis voilà on en a fait on
n'a pas le choix du mot du coup c'était
le chalumeau dès que c'était avant s'ils
font qu un
bur un marteau chalumeau vrai travail de
nuit quoi et en fait écouter tes voisins
étaient persuadés qu'ils étaient
boulangers quand tu auras n'est pas du
tout quoi non mais même en plus c'est
une une belle bouteille parce que des
fois les premiers on emmenait les
coffres carrément on les anglais ont les
emmenant les odeurs dans les garages du
quartier ont découpé les coffres forts
d'un gain et après on a carrément amené
le matos sur place dans les grandes
surfaces dans les dents les banques et
tous et ont découpé les coffres forts et
nous on pensait donc à ça c'était notre
vie quoi c'était on avait grandi c'est
vrai c'était si tu allais faire carrière
ouais pour moi pour moi c'était j'ai
appris tout gamma gt on était les
gavroches du quartier à faire que ce à
quoi alors tav et a creusé ensuite un
tunnel pour rejoindre les coffres de la
société générale
oui voilà ça c'est là tu t'es fait
continent il ya une raison c'est parce
que on est et ricard dans le
centre-ville à chaque fois qu'on se
faisait contrôler on était tellement
connue et à un moment j'ai dit les gars
on va passer en dessous ce dans les
égouts c'est comme les rues de calais
plaque de les mêmes rues c'est pareil
sauf que des fois faut être en bateau
parce que c'est il ya des egos et les
égouts quand vous arrêtez en bateau
ouais on était dans les égouts on à
visiter les égouts ont visité et là on a
vu une bouche d'égout qui étaient
proches de la banque
et donc dans nos têtes on sait ni bah
ouais on va creuser un tunnel et on
avait vu en plus que la salle des
coffres savoir on avait fait tous le
plan fin voilà et donc pendant quatre
mois on a creusé le tunnel pendant
quatre mois et à cause d'une petite
erreur de notre part
voilà pendant quatre mois tu aurais
mieux fait de travailler quoi bein c'est
ce que je dis on dit dans les quartiers
que ceux des chômeurs des fois rien des
bons à rien ou quoi mais non quand on
bosse on bosse et on à la spaggiari
à la spaggiari nous ont contrariés sinon
tu t'es fait tu t'es fait coincer je me
suis fait coincer vous êtes dans le
tunnel
alors non moi la sortie du tunnel il m'a
sorti à la sortie du tien je me fais
coincé avec un ami tous les autres ont
réussi à se barrer est arrivé au
commissariat garde à vue j'étais connu
comme le loup blanc et il me transfert
d'un commissariat un autre pour
m'interroger à la pop la pj et là dans
la voiture une comparer justement
spaggiari et le policier qui était à
côté de moi et me diras tu sais que tu
es nouveau spaggiari quand ça et ebit a
plus qu'à faire comme spaggiari n'a mis
quatre mois pour s'évader
cinq minutes plus tard j'étais évadé
alors on va nous raconter
ares est vrai parce que vous êtes
arrêtés menottés dans un camion de
police
et qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce camion
de police et bien moi depuis tout gamin
j'avais une façon particulière de me
faire claquer les menottes jusque là
caméra et je priais bien mon pouce a
fait que si je les claques et ici par
exemple toi et que tu tombe tombe de ton
point tu gagnes un jeu et donc j'avais
juste à péter m'ont tous comme ça et là
je pouvais dire la salle j'étais attaché
comme ça il délirait sur moi ouais il
rigolait il dit vas-y rigole on va dans
5 minutes tu vas pas d'un client tu vas
en enfer nature mois ferme à main est
donc là j'avais tiré ma menottes et une
comparé à spaggiari mais réellement il
était là tu sais qu'il n'est ce pas un
nouveau spaggiari tu quand tout a
toujours fait des trucs sans violence
toujours sans violence j'ai voilà je
joue pour moi voilà fallait faire
marcher sa tête et puis on est donc là
tu te relèves des menottes
donc non je les enlève pas tout de suite
ils me sortent du véhicule et me disent
par contre si on a un cas baiser
spaggiari gilbert avons essayé qu'à
baiser spaggiari
on peut pas te le dire il dit bah dites
le moi il est mort spaggiari non non on
peut pas te le dire ils me font avancer
comme ça jeudi mais dit le mans il est
mort et avant même que je pose mon pied
sur la première marche de la préfecture
dit voulais vraiment pas me dire qui a
baisé spaggiari non dérapante 10
rapports volte face je suis parti en
courant
ils m'ont coursé là il y en a une cour
et derrière il arrête toi arrête arrête
toi je t'en supplie que je n'avais pas
faire mieux
[Rires]
ne faut pas le faire tout ça tout ce
qu'il est c'est vrai christine
absolument d'accord parce que là on en
rigole mais parce que vous allez voir
qu'après david il est rentré dans si je
peux donner des pistons mais voilà
exactement c'est si je peux si je peux
justement parce que je sais que devant
la télé les gens ils vont dire il fait
l'apologie krieg all the way moi j'ai
décidé de le raconter de façon
humoristique que tu fasses spectacle
voilà je fais un spectacle et j'ai
préféré arriver sur scène
de cette façon là en rigolant et tous
tout en envoyant des messages bien sûr
est que parce que si j'étais arrivé on
le fait dans les écoles les collèges les
prisons on va d'ailleurs si j'arrivais
devant les détenus et si je le faisais
attention c'est pas beau de volets un
volet paul on va faire la morale à
quelqu'un de bien sûr bien aidé à
remplir le frigo après on parle on
écoute beaucoup plus quelqu'un qui nous
fait rire la vitre et puis surtout du
vrai qui les passionne comme dans un
choc et c'est là tu peux envoyer tes
messages subtilement temps verra les
messages assez sûrs alors on réussit
c'est donc à vous échapper fait et là
vous allez ouvrir alors j'arrive à
m'échapper déjà je me cache dans un
buisson et
je pense que c'était le 24 24 décembre
1980 81 18 la veille de noël et donc
18h30 je sors de mes nuits sont on est
en plein centre ville
et là j'attends un petit peu je mets le
long d'un petit mur un couple arrive
vers moi avec une poussette une amie
avec avez une poussette
là je sais pas pourquoi mais c'était eux
il arrive à ma hauteur je regarde le
monsieur jeudi excusez moi monsieur de
vous déranger
j'ai mis un petit frère qui s'est
arraché le tout le douala sur la grille
ma soeur l'emmener aux urgences j'ai pas
de nouvelles ça fait déjà plus de quatre
heures vous pouvez pas m'emmener aux
urgences le mec me regarde il me fait
asma serbie et namas neufchef galerie
nadar me arras nos regards
il me disant en arabe qu'il parlait pas
un mot de français qui paraît que arabe
je les regarde et je lui dis en fait il
m'a dit laisse moi venir dans
l'automobile ahmed - loué le talent
c'est ça avec vous accueillera problème
création on y croit mais on apprend les
langues essentiellement de femmes et
sincère et donc la famille choix quand
même j'apprenais l'italie et là il me
regarde il me dit par contre serbie les
amstaff alcôves benchenane calme il me
disant que je monte dans le kop haskell
avec une 4 places si vous n'êtes pas se
mettre hors la loi ça c'était très bien
pour toi moi j'ai ça m'arrangeait au
contraire il met tout en entendant le
corps je me disais les arabes ils savent
se [ __ ] dans la merde quand même parce
que je connais et laisse rattraper que
moi dans le coffre il prend au sein de
malfaiteurs le mec t'as le pot c'est un
amour ce mois là non mais c'est un amour
voilà donc quand je suis monté dans le
coffre on est on arrivé au quartier
j'ai quitté ces braves gens tout ça j'ai
retrouvé mes potes nemir atm voilà tous
tous mes potes mais là là il mourir on a
récupéré trois voitures on a gagné la
capitale on était à caen dans le
calvados
on est arrivé à paris sans encombre et
l'âge et voilà j'ai bénéficié de l'aide
de plein d'amis tous ensuite j'étais
chez les indiens dans l'arrière-pays
niçois
vous avez une cousine qui vivait comme
des indiens la ses meilleurs plans que
vit haïti sans téléphone sans rien avec
l'au-delà puis le lait enfin voilà il ya
des indiens
ouais il appelle ça comme ça c'est le
code ces communautés c'est vrai ils
vivent dans des bidons les appelle les
indiens non j'ai dit il et hippies dans
des types identifier contrôler mais
qu'en fait c'est quoi
c'est dans un délire mais moi ça
m'arrange et donc voilà cela fait donc
j'ai passé un long moment je vois là
j'ai appris j'ai rejoint mes potes au
bout de deux mois j'ai rejoint mes potes
à paris et là j'ai appelé mon petit
frère tout les perquisitions chez moi
chez mes parents chez me d'hôtes en tout
cas alors justement la télévision contre
l'évasion de david et donc tu te vois à
la télé ouais je me non ils mettent pas
ma photo il voyait tout le parquet
estime ce truc c'est rachid arhab le
présentateur du jt de 20 heures c'était
donc le jeudi 24 décembre 98 donc il
parle de vous alors que vous êtes à
table en train de regarder la télé
tranquille avec des gens que vous ne
connaissez pas voilà je suis en plein
repas et il ya même le monsieur à côté
de moi des moins chères en train de
rigoler et on rigole bien d'un coup de
main on voit le truc est le monsieur me
regarde il fait lui là on peut lui
souhaiter un joyeux noël quand même
ouais bah tu as pas dit il aura tout de
suite mais là j'étais je dis bah avait
complètement mdi bomba d'accord il a
voulu cambrioler une banque mais sans
arme et sans violence non bitumée
monsieur j'adhère complètement à céder
[ __ ]